- So Mark, so far we've talked a lot
about device security and
when we talk about devices
at least in my mind, I imagine my phone,
I imagine my laptop, a
tablet, maybe a smart watch,
but there's actually a much
broader universe of devices,
smart devices, you
know, smart light bulbs,
things we might put on things
so that we don't lose them.
How does that play into this whole notion
of device security?
Should we just, you know, not worry
about the smart light bulb or
whatever else we might buy?
Or should that also be
part of the picture?
- I worry about smart devices a little bit
and the reason is that we've now got,
I just scratched myself in shot,
comparable power to what was
on the original space shuttle,
inside that light bulb,
inside that wall switch.
Now, for the most part,
they're not doing that much.
They don't have access
usually to your data.
You know, if it has a camera or something,
that's another issue.
But literally for a light
bulb, the biggest concern
is that it has access
to your home network.
It's on that same wifi
with your laptop and your
phone and your tablet,
and they may be sharing
sensitive information.
So for that reason, what
I tend to do is to not buy
the absolute cheapest
light bulb I can find,
because those companies,
with their very thin profit
margins often don't update
that you know, tiny little computer
that's inside the light bulb,
so it may have vulnerabilities,
it may have weaknesses
that hackers can exploit.
There are actually a few
examples of that happening.
So in this case,
what happened is somebody
found a vulnerability
affecting millions and
millions of light bulbs
and switches and smart
toasters and what have you,
and they were able to
get them all to wake up
at the same time and to
hit one particular website
until that website was overwhelmed
and couldn't keep up with the traffic.
That's called a denial of service attack.
And so by doing that,
they were able to use
lots of innocent people's
smart light bulbs
and smart toasters to do some real damage.
So scary, scary crimes
not affecting the person
in the house, but affecting, you know,
some victim down the road.
Again, the best solution to this
is getting devices that
are updated and patched,
that do receive those
same security updates
that you get on your phone or your laptop.
And most of the reputable
brands, you know,
certainly the Google
Nest devices, but most
of the reputable brands will
have those security updates,
so you'll be in a pretty good place there.